Hello and thank you for joining us on
I'd like to know our Bible question and
answer program. To my right, Pastor
Steven Boore, founder and president. To
my left, Pastor David Salazar, general
manager of our Latina network. And I'm
CA Murray. And thank you for joining us
today. You give the Bible questions. By
the grace of God, we will give you the
Bible answers. Should you have a
question to send to us, we'd love to
have it and encourage you to do so by
sending your question to TV at some su
as in marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org
and we will get to your questions just
as soon as we possibly can. And we thank
you in advance for your patience and for
sending in your Bible questions. Pastor
Salazar, would you ask God's blessing on
our sitting today and then we'll launch
right out.
>> Absolutely. Let us pray.
Gracious heavenly father, we are so
thankful to come before you to be able
to open your word and to be able to uh
study and and give answers that are
according to your will. We pray that you
will lead us through the Holy Spirit so
that our answers may be in harmony with
your word and may bring those who are
watching and listening a clear
understanding of your Bible. We pray
this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Mary S. We do not have a
place where she's coming from, but um
she thanks us for the ministry and says
that is a blessing, which is something
pastor Boore we always like to hear.
>> Amen.
>> And which we find encouraging. Um
she is concerned about Isaiah chapter 7
and verse 14. Isaiah 7 and verse 14. And
then she has a question that sort of uh
stems out of that and she wants a little
explanation of verse 16 of that same
verse uh same chapter rather. So let's
go to Isaiah chapter 7 and uh verse 14.
Pastor, do you have that?
>> Yeah, I do. Let me read it for you. This
is in the King New King James Version.
It says, "Therefore, the Lord himself
will give you a sign. Behold, the virgin
shall conceive and bear a son, and shall
call his name Emmanuel.
And verse 16,
>> for before the child shall know to
refuse the evil, and choose the good to
land that you dread will be forsaken by
both her kings.
>> All righty. So let's let's separate them
for just a moment in our in our answer
and then it I think it tend takes to
make tends to make a little more sense.
The first question is is this child this
virgin child is this text speaking about
Jesus? Is Jesus Emmanuel? Um
that one is fairly easy actually uh
because there are many many places in
the Bible that state that. But who wants
to weigh in on that?
Well, first of all, we need to
understand that um the Jewish uh
scholars and uh the Jewish Bible
students use typology.
>> In other words, uh type antitype. Uh the
type is never as perfect as the
antitype.
>> Correct.
>> Uh you have for example, Jesus is called
a lamb.
>> Well, without intending to be
disrespectful, uh Jesus is not a woolly
creature.
>> Exactly. uh uh you know with four legs.
Um there are certain aspects of of the
lamb that apply to Christ.
>> Mhm.
>> Like uh its purity uh like it's um it's
peaceful uh you know there there are
certain things about the lamb that
actually represent Christ
>> but the type is not as perfect as the
antitype. Um, you know, you have, for
example, Moses, uh, in the Old
Testament, he's the deliverer of Israel,
>> but you can't apply all of the details
of the deliverance of Israel, uh, to
Christ.
>> There's a pattern that's similar, but
all the details are not identical.
>> And so, so really what you have in
Isaiah chapter 7 is typology.
>> The deliverance that was that took place
in the days of Isaiah now becomes a
symbol, a greater symbol of the
deliverance that comes through Christ.
Mhm.
>> And and it's interesting to see that in
this particular verse um we see these
two types or these symbols that are
mentioned. Number one, it says behold a
virgin
shall conceive. Now that in itself it's
uh pointing to prophecy that cannot be
fulfilled unless the Lord intervenes. A
virgin by default would never conceive
unless she was to become connected with
a man.
>> Sure. But in this particular case the
prophecy and the symbol here is that
there will be the sign will be that a
virgin who has no has not known any man
would be become pregnant and the child
that will be coming out of her would be
Emmanuel and that that's an actually a
name that points to the Messiah. It says
God is with us or uh with that is with
us is God that is the name means. So
it's really
making it very clear, very direct that
not only would God become men, become
flesh, but will also be born of a
virgin. Therefore, the only
um person that could fulfill that
particular sign, that particular
prophecy is Jesus himself. Uh and of
course God became flesh. He dwelt among
us. He took our human nature. He took
our infirmities. He took our uh you know
existence or nature so that he could be
the perfect example. Well said pastor
you know the the symbol of the lamb also
applies to Christ. And so in this
particular case in that particular verse
verse 14 it's without a doubt speaking
of Jesus. And and this is why some of
these verses are are even hard for um
some of Jewish to admit uh you know
because they're fulfilled in Jesus and
and for them these are problematic as
Christ fulfilled that particular um
verse very well as actually in even
Matthew speaks of that sign. So um you
know that's what we can say. Now verse
regarding verse 16 uh I believe it's
interesting to see that um it tells the
character of that child he will refuse
the evil and choose the good and we see
the power of choice of Christ he elected
to choose the right always submitting to
his father that gives you the the the
sense of a life of perfection of perfect
obedience that Christ had. So these two
verses really
clearly define the role of Jesus and
since childhood he chose to do the right
to follow the lord and to be perfect in
obedience.
>> You know there's another example of uh
this principle.
Um there's a text that says out of Egypt
I called my son.
>> Uh you know in its historical context
God called Israel out of Egypt.
>> Correct?
>> Israel is God's son. Mhm.
>> But that is used in the New Testament to
speak about uh Jesus coming with uh
Joseph and Mary out of Egypt back to the
promised land.
>> Precisely.
>> Uh so so in other words, we're dealing
with typology.
>> What happened once
>> applies in the future to the Messiah.
And and of course only an inspired
writer
>> can make the application of the type to
the antitype. And so and so when Matthew
says, "Out of Egypt I called my son,"
>> God is showing through uh Matthew who is
inspired as he writes his book that that
text in the Old Testament has not only a
historical application, it also has an
application uh in the future which is
greater. You know, there are many terms
that we tend to throw around as as
Adventists who are used to handling the
Bible,
>> which um the general world does not use
as much as we do. When I was younger, I
I used to get very confused with type
and antiype. I thought antype was type
and type was antit. I learned you got to
flip that type is the shadow and and
antitype is the real is the real thing,
>> right? The shadow may contain aspects of
the antitype but may not totally
encompass that because Judas Jesus is a
lamb. He's also a lion, you know. So
there are different aspects that are
emphasized at different times. So the
type does not totally
>> lay on top of the antitype, but it does
give you a clue by covering certain
aspects of the antitype. Think of type
as the the the pattern and antitype as
the real thing.
>> Right. Right. You know it's as it's
another example would be when Abraham
takes his son to sacrifice him on Mount
>> Moriah.
>> You know there are aspects that are
applicable like for example uh the agony
of the father in giving up his son
>> and the son's uh willingness you know
not trying to escape yes being willing
submitting to his father. Um but but you
know Isaac was not sacrificed
>> right?
>> You know there was a substitute other
than Isaac that was offered. Now uh in
Hebrews 11 it also says that in a
certain sense in a parabolic sense the
word is paralle.
>> Uh Abraham received his son
>> resurrected on the third day.
>> Yeah.
>> But he didn't literally resurrect like
Jesus did. So, so in other words, in
type and anti-ype, you have
similarities, but you don't have
identical.
>> There you go. Very well said. And I
think one of the interesting ways when
you're studying the word of God is to
see the the uh the prophetic aspect.
You're reading something, it may have a
very concrete explanation, that time,
that place, but then there's the
secondary, which is the um the type of
the antitype, which comes later. So it's
it's a good way to study the Bible and
to make sure you understand what's
happening when you are indeed going into
uh the study of the word. Uh Mrs. S,
whose name we don't totally have. Thank
you for the question. Very good
question. And um oh just to give you a a
couple texts because there are texts
that talk about Emmanuel being God in
the Old Testament and Isaiah and of
course uh Matthew right off the bat in
Matthew 128 says interpreting God with
us. So it's Old Testament and and New.
one of the easier things to to uh sort
of work your way through in the word of
God because it's stated very plainly
>> and historically speaking because
there's a second question here uh how do
you explain verse 16 uh just very
briefly uh there's a historical
fulfillment to that which is um Syria
and Samaria a couple of years within two
years later uh the kings Hosa and Resin
were were killed
And so and so that verse has a
historical fulfillment. Not everything
in Isaiah 7 applies to the apo applies
to the Messiah.
>> True.
>> You know there are certain things that
God says later with a later prophet. He
says this applies exactly
>> to the Messiah.
>> Very good.
>> All righty. Thank you so very much. That
was question uh 137. 38
comes to us from we know it's from
California though it is anonymous um
how do we interpret the instit
institution of slavery that was allowed
to the children of Israel as far as I
understand it there were Israelites who
became slave servant slaves of their own
valition due to poverty sort of
indentured servants actually and there
were laws governing their management
that statement is But I also understand
that there were non-Israelites who were
slaves forever and were considered
property that was passed down uh passed
down family lines. What kind of slavery
allowed to persist and even
institutionalized? What was that kind of
slavery that was allowed to persist and
even institutionalized? I can start by
by by
looking at one institution uh situation
where slaves were made slaves forever
and that of course was the Gibeonites um
who tried to pull a fast one for one of
a better term on on Joshua and the
children of Israel.
>> Um
their lot was to be destroyed.
>> Uh and they realized that because all of
the nations around them were being taken
over by by Israel. And so they tricked
their way into and and reading in
Joshua, you'll find this a very
interesting uh story. Joshua chapter 9
and got a promise from from him that uh
they would not be destroyed. When it was
found out that their tre treachery was
indeed treachery, uh the default setting
was all right, we will not destroy you,
but you'll be slaves for life. Um Ellen
White gives us some information by
saying um uh evidently they were not
only slaves they actually were what's
the word I want grafted in became part
of uh the Israel proper in that later on
they are fighting with Israel. So their
their their situation had changed
somewhat because they had accepted they
their lot with Israel and had followed
them and had become part of them and had
accepted them as not. I think the big
question is when we think of slavery,
pastor Bor, pastor uh Salazar, we tend
to to fixate ourselves on Roman slavery
and that peculiar American institution
of slavery and biblical slavery was not
that and we know it was not that because
Ellen White says God punished our
country for the for the high crime of
slavery. God does not take kind of the
people owning other people and misusing
other people. So he punished the north
and he punished the south. One for
practicing it, other for profiting from
it. So we're not talking about that kind
of kind of slavery. So gentlemen, you
can take it from there.
>> Well, you know, pastor CA, it's very
important that you said to make the
distinction between the uh Hebrew laws
of slavery versus what we normally
understand of slavery. the Greek G Greco
Roman world type of slavery is the one
that we are more familiar with uh or or
even the uh trade slave that happened in
in the modern colonial uh slavery as as
we have seen in in recent history in
this world in in in this country and
this particular type of slavery is not
what the Bible uh uh granted the Hebrews
to have. It was not based on race or uh
concept of becoming uh possession as the
way they had it in in in these you know
modern types of slavery. So we have to
remember that the slavery was more
closer to indentured service debt relief
and social protection not exploitation.
Even the example you mentioned, the Gav
Gavinites who were Gibianites were who
were enslaved. They actually had uh two
things to do. Bring water and bring
wood. But they had their own families.
They could live. They had their own
land. They could have certain aspect of
freedom in their experience. Now there
is a chapter in and there's a several
places in the Bible but chapter 25 of
Leviticus gives us the base from where
our our question comes from. Uh
Leviticus 25
>> starting from verse 39 and on we have
the laws of slavery. But uh and we can
actually read some of them so we can
understand how the Lord applied slavery
for the Jews. And then we're going to
see how he granted type of slavery that
appears to be one that is perpetual.
Let's look at that uh verse 39 chapter
25 of Leviticus. I'm going to read uh
till um till verse 46.
It says there, "And if one of your
brethren who dwells by you becomes poor
and sells himself to you, you shall not
compel him to serve as a slave,
>> as a higher servant, and a sojourer. He
shall be with you, and shall serve you
until the year of Jubilee. And then he
shall depart from you, he and his
children, with him, and shall return to
his own family. He returned to the
possession of his fathers. For they are
my servants whom I brought out of the
land of Egypt. They shall not be sold as
slaves. You shall not rule over him with
rigor, but you shall fear your God. And
as for your male and female slaves whom
you may have, from the nations that are
around you, from then you may buy male
and female slaves. Moreover, you may buy
the children of these strangers who
dwell among you and their families who
are with you, which they begget in your
land, and they shall become your
property, and you may take them as an
inheritance of your to your for your
children after you to inherit them as a
possession. They shall be your permanent
slaves, but regarding your brethren, the
children of Israel, you shall not rule
over one another with rigor. So, in this
particular chapter or these verses, we
can see that there are two types
distinctions. the ones that are among
the children of Israel, they could not
be slaves necessarily. They were just uh
servants. But then you could buy from
the strangers, from the foreigners. You
could have them and buy them to become
your servants permanently or even
inherit them. However, there is a
distinction because the rules of
treatment to these individuals were all
to be applied equally. For example, the
slaves, even the Bible, I mean, God
himself said that they had all to rest
on the seventh day Sabbath.
>> Even the servants, they had a day off.
They could, you couldn't use them on the
Sabbath day. You couldn't have them do
your chores or do whatever. They were to
rest on that seventh day Sabbath. Not
only that, if you were to uh be hard on
them, abuse them, they had the
right to escape, to flee if you were a a
a strong ruler. Actually, we see this in
Deuteronomy chapter 23 15 and 16 just to
show you that if you were mistreating a
a slave and he escaped, he was he was
not to be returned. It says there, I'm
going to read there, verse 16 and 15 and
16 of Deuteronomy 23. You shall not give
back to his master the slave who was who
has escaped from his master to you. He
may dwell with you in your midst in the
place which he chooses within one of
your gates where it seems best to him.
You shall not oppress him. So if a slave
was being mistreated, he had the right
to escape that household that that that
master. So this is how the Lord
protected even those who were from
foreign nations and who were perhaps
victims of this the trade of slaves but
under the household of a Jewish
individual they were not to mistreat
them abuse them or use them as uh things
as items without any respect of being a
person. So there was a big difference
between these two that I could see in
the word of God. Well, there I'm sorry,
pastor. Where you going?
>> And two further points.
>> Number one,
a close relative
could free
uh another relative that had sold
himself.
>> Yeah.
>> Because of financial difficulty. uh the
very next verse in the passage that you
read in Leviticus.
>> Uh now if a sojourer or stranger close
to you becomes rich and one of your
brethren who dwells by him becomes poor
and sells himself to the stranger or
soldier close to you or to a member of
the stranger's family after he is sold
he may be redeemed again. One of his
brothers may redeem him. In other words,
one of his brothers could pay the price.
>> Also, um an individual who um was a
slave
um could actually choose to remain a
>> with the master forever
>> by piercing an ear and putting an
earring on the ear.
>> Um which means that u you know they were
not treated terribly because I sure
wouldn't want to have my ear pierced. I
want to stay if I was being mistreated.
Now, it's interesting that the word
rigor is used.
>> Yes, that's the word I was
>> the the Bible draws a very clear
contrast between uh slaves as we
understand them in early United States
history
>> and the slavery that existed in the
Roman Empire. In the Roman Empire, the
slave was basically property that could
be disposed of any way that the person
wanted to.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and and you know, in the Bible, we
have an example of that. slavery. Uh the
children of Israel in Egypt,
>> the the word rigor that you use, they
would not slaves were not be treated
with rigor.
>> Correct.
>> That word is used in Exodus
>> chapter 1 speaking about the slavery of
Israel. This this was worldly slavery.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh it says it there in verse uh 11.
>> Therefore, they set task masters over
them to afflict them
>> with their burdens. And they built for
Pharaoh supply cities, Pitham and
Ramses.
But the more they afflicted them, the
more they multiplied and grew, and they
were in dread of the children of Israel.
And then verse 13, so the Egyptians made
the children of Israel served with
>> rigor.
>> And they made their lives bitter, with
hard bondage, in mortar and brick, and
in all manner of service in the field.
All their servth in which they made them
serve was with rigor. So that is
slavery.
>> Very different slavery than what we
find. Yeah.
>> Uh in the rules that God established in
contrast to the ancient world.
>> And one of the first things God said is
when you come into the land and possess
it
>> uh and you have servants, do not make
them serve with rigor. So whatever rigor
was, don't you do it, you know, because
it's not negative. Um, one of the things
in the reading that you um read, Pastor
Salazar, jumped out at me
>> was uh this idea of uh if a slave
escapes, do not return him. Uh, in in
this country when the fugitive slave law
was passed, Ellen White says first of
all, it was demonic and it was designed
to squeeze out any bit of care or
concern or compassion that the slave
master would hold hold for the for for
the slave. uh the law made it not only
illegal but mandatory. You had to return
your slaves or you were you were uh
punished yourself. So it goes directly
against what the Bible is saying, right?
Uh if they if they are being treated
cruel and they get away, don't return
them. United States says return them
under any. So to make a parallel from
biblical slavery to what we're are
accustomed to is is not fair. We do
ourselves and the Bible an injustice.
There were very strong rules as to how
to treat and really this was in some
ways uh pastor bore pastor salazar a bit
of a welfare system to take care of
people who could not take care of
themselves right and of course there was
there was a limited time you weren't a
slave forever unless you chose to be so
the body was being very very
>> uh we think negative but actually it's
being very positive right in in doing
something for those who were uh in
various situations. So good question
again and we thank you so very much uh
anonymous from California. God bless
you. Well our show is over for this
time. Our time has slipped into
eternity. Allow me to wish you grace and
peace through God's blessing and the
presence of Jesus Christ. Bye-bye and
God bless.